[Música]
i
buenas tardes cómo les va
bien que según la organización de las
naciones unidas en los próximos 30 años
la población mundial va a crecer casi
dos mil millones de personas es decir
que esperamos saber casi diez mil
millones de habitantes en todo el
planeta tierra
obviamente que como consecuencia de esto
vamos a tener que incrementar lo que es
la producción de alimentos y según la
fao que es una dependencia de la
voluntad que se aboque principalmente lo
que es la agricultura y los alimentos
vamos a tener que incrementar la
producción agrícola en casi un 70% o sea
así tal cual lo escucharon casi un 70%
más de producción agrícola lo que
estamos produciendo hoy
para poder alimentarlos y esto estamos a
30 años de que ocurra no para el año
2050 no más
obviamente la agricultura moderna se
viene trabajando en estos días hace
varios años e inclusive reconocemos que
existe lo que es el mejoramiento
genético de semillas la producción y
síntesis de fertilizantes químicos de
sustancias o productos fitosanitarios o
técnicas y manejos de cultivos pero
un poco la idea es preguntarnos si está
en la mejor forma que tenemos de
producir alimentos habrá algunas otras
maneras de producirlo de alguna manera
que seamos menos invasivos con el medio
ambiente
vamos a hacer para para lograr esta
producción e incrementar esta producción
de alimentos sin generar un daño o un
impacto negativo sobre todo el planeta y
todos sus habitantes
entonces el desafío no es solamente
incrementar la producción de alimento
los próximos 30 años sino es hacerlo una
manera totalmente sustentable e inocua
les pido que dejemos esto por unos
minutos de lado imaginemos que no
estamos en un campo agrícola o en
contacto con la naturaleza en un bosque
y que de algunas formas pudiéramos hacer
como una especie de zoom por debajo y
mirar en forma microscópica debajo de
nuestros pies y vamos a encontrar a
millones de pequeños seres vivos
coexistiendo conformando lo que se
conoce como un hábitat oa lo mejor si
plan escuchaba nombrar lo que es un
microbioma es decir un microbioma es un
conjunto de organismos muy pequeños que
coexisten entre ellos con toda su
información genética están arreglando
relacionándose entre ellos y con otros
organismos de otra especie y con el
medio ambiente
estos seres vivos son los primeros seres
vivos que colonizaron el planeta tierra
estamos hablando que apareció en hace
casi 3.500 millones de años o sea son
los seres vivos más antiguos y más
adaptados que conocemos
cuando hablamos de estos seres vivos son
son microorganismos que son tan
importantes que inclusive ahora desde el
año 2010 se comenzó a trabajar lo que es
el proyecto en microbioma del planeta
tierra que quiero decir aquí que ya que
apunte este proyecto en otras palabras
lo que hace es tratar de alguna manera
de armar tu mapa del planeta tierra y
ubicar a todos estos microorganismos que
colonizan la tierra esto es un esfuerzo
colaborativo en casi más de 500
científicos de todo el mundo es un
ejemplo típico de lo que sería la
ciencia abierta y colaborativa y cuál es
la mirada y la visión de esto es poder
entender cuáles son estas tendencias
ecológicas globales ahora ustedes me
dirán bueno porque cuanto estos
organismos estos pequeños
microorganismos como lo llamamos
microbios
son pequeños seres vivos que estamos
todo el tiempo en contacto con ellos
aunque aunque no lo veamos
estamos hablando de bacterias de virus
de levaduras las levaduras las que
usamos las que se hace para hacer el pan
por ejemplo o para hacer el vino o la
cerveza son las artesanas la hora que
tanto se consume está bien que también
se utilizan para producir lo que son
todas estas energías renovables por
ejemplo para transformar el azúcar que
tiene un grano de maíz en bioetanol es
necesario una levadura y eso se lleva a
cabo tras un proceso que se conoce como
fermentación entonces este grupo de
microorganismos conforme a lo que son
los microbiomas
escuchando hablar de lo que es el
microbioma o la microbiota intestinal
algunos o si les digo flora intestinal
los mejores son un poquito más bueno la
flora intestinal no es más ni menos que
un conjunto de bacterias que colonizan
nuestro tracto digestivo nos ayudan a
digerir los alimentos y además nos
previenen del ataque de otros organismos
patógenos que nos pueden causar una
enfermedad entonces
estos microbio más existen para los
humanos para los animales hay microbio
más en la tierra y también existe
microbio más en las plantas que quiero
decir un conjunto de microorganismos que
interaccionan con las plantas haciendo
que lo que se conoce como una especie de
simbiosis o mutualismo en donde a ambos
organismos se benefician y esta relación
del microbioma entre planta y organismos
data de casi 200 millones de años son
200 millones de años que se vienen
relacionando entre ellos si generan un
efecto benéfico para ambos en la
agricultura moderno y empleamos algunos
de estos estos microorganismos por
ejemplo estamos trabajando en algunos
cultivos con bacterias que lo que hacen
los ponemos en contacto con las plantas
y le proveen a la planta el nitrógeno
que la planta necesita nitrógeno el
principal nutriente de la planta y la
planta que provee alimentos esta
bacteria o sea que estamos de alguna
forma reemplazando un fertilizante
químico si por una bacteria y no
solamente es el reemplazo por un ser
vivo y totalmente natural sino que
además éste es mucho más eficiente y
cuesta casi 10 veces menos o sea dato
interesante
entonces volviendo un tema un poquito al
eje central de la charla lo que les
comentaba recién que esta agricultura
moderna de alguna manera a través del
empleo de algunos fungicidas e
insecticidas o herbicidas
si buscamos que interrumpir este
dinamismo que había entre estos
microorganismos y las plantas
qué es parece si les comento que o qué
opinan ustedes yo si no nos parece que
sería muy interesante de alguna forma de
volver a identificar cuáles son estos
microorganismos y ponernos nuevamente en
conjunto con estas plantas para poder de
alguna forma llevar adelante una
agricultura ahora mucho más sustentable
y mucho más amigable con el medio
ambiente estamos hablando que son que
estos este mutualismo y esta simbiosis
entre estos microorganismos y las
plantas datan como les decía recién de
200 millones de años o sea han generar
un equilibrio entre esos no de lo que en
otras palabras estoy hablando es lo que
se conoce como el biomimetismo el
biomimetismo es tratar de alguna forma
de copiarle naturales o sea lo que
hacemos es inspirarnos en naturaleza
para que de alguna manera nos provea
soluciones tecnológicas de vanguardia y
que en este caso como lo es la
producción agrícola que sean totalmente
sustentables con el tiempo o sea
esto es algo que
[Música]
desde hace 10 años con un grupo de
microbiólogos desde el río cuarto
venimos trabajando con este propósito
con esta mirada de alguna manera de
tratar de identificar cuáles son estos
microorganismos en conjunto con
obviamente y apalancando los muchos con
la ciencia con la comunidad científica
trabajando mucho con esto del proyecto
de microbioma para entender cuáles son
estos microorganismos y de alguna manera
en nuestro emprendimiento en nuestra
empresa tratamos de reproducirlos y
volverlos a poner en contacto con la
agricultura o sea por ejemplo tiro uno
de ejemplo en tantas líneas estamos
trabajando estamos empleando bacterias
que producen sustancias que son bio
fungicidas o sea estas bacterias
lo que hacen es impedir el ataque de
hongos patógenos sobre las plantas que
le causan un daño y por lo pronto por lo
tanto disminuyen lo que es el
rendimiento
como les comentaba recién es para
nosotros nuestro propósito nuestra
mirada es lo que queremos hacer es
transformar de una manera esta
agricultura moderna mediante el empleo
de estos microorganismos en la
agricultura del futuro no de alguna
forma imitando lo que hace naturaleza
que tiene casi 200 millones de años de
conocimiento y de experiencia o sea es
producir más con menos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]